[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ce nouveau numéro du sky
échos les missions qui vous racontent la
vie des acteurs économiques du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
nous sommes à voisins le bretonneux
devant le pub o dan pâtit le secteur
café et restauration prépare sa
réouverture progressive à partir du 19
mai et jusqu'au 30 juin avec la levée
des restrictions sanitaires une
réouverture après six mois de fermeture
c'est ce que vous découvrirez dans ce
17e numéro du sky et qu ils sont dans
les starting blocks à partir du 19 mai
les acteurs de la restauration pourront
relancer leurs activités
une réouverture après plus de six mois
de quasi arrêt l'heure est à la
préparation la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles yvelines
mobiliser face aux risques de
défaillance des entreprises un réseau
dédié à la prévention a été mise en
place
enfin découvert deux pros tera
environnement société installée à
trappes
une aventure entrepreneuriale qui dure
depuis plus de vingt ans on commence ce
sky aequo avec le déplacement du
ministre délégué en charge des petites
et moyennes entreprises alain griset
s'est rendu à montfort l'amaury le
mercredi 12 mai pour rencontrer les
commerçants une semaine avant la
réouverture des commerces
l'occasion pour nous de l'interroger sur
l'accompagnement des pme et des tpe pour
relancer leurs activités
on écoute tout de suite le ministre au
micro de bixente mais rien senti steban
il ya des situations particulières par
exemple dans le vêtement dans la
chaussure pour lequel nous avons avec
bono le maire travailler la semaine
dernière en particulier vous avez raison
sur la trésorerie pour reconstituer un
stock donc nous allons travailler avec
les banques pour qui un dispositif à
dock permettant de reconstituer ce stock
par ailleurs vous savez que ils ont
bénéficié du fonds de solidarité
renforcée c'est ou 10000 euros par
rapport à part du chiffre d'affaires
ouvert pour son chiffre d'affaires et
qu'il y a eu un dispositif stocks pour
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
qui correspond à 80% du fonds de
solidarité du mois de novembre qui va
être versée à partir du 25 mai
[Musique]
les restaurants vont ouvrir
progressivement à partir du 19 mai et
jusqu'au 30 juin avec la levée des
restrictions sanitaires et pour parler
des préparatifs de la réouverture nous
sommes avec sébastien farge autres
dirigeants duo donne pâtit bonjour
bonjour enfanter
alors dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
et comment vous allez vous préparer dans
un bon état d'esprit sachant que sur
toute la vaccination avant donc je pense
que les échéances du ministre vont être
tenu comme ce qui s'est passé avant donc
je pense que là dessus on est on est pas
mal après on a quelques encore
négociations à faire au niveau de la
restauration au niveau des jauges de 50%
sur les terrasses qui reste un petit peu
un petit peu compliqué au niveau de sa
soit l'année des terrasses soient
grandes ou pas c'est que 50 %
donc ça c'est encore en négociation vous
est fermée depuis le 30 octobre 2020
tout à fait enfin on est fermé pour la
peau la plupart des restaurants ils ont
dû fermer leurs portes nous on a
continué
à faire de la vente en porte et
principalement pour avoir une relation
vraiment avec la clientèle et puis
continuer dans une optique de jamais co2
jamais coupé puis gardé un tout petit
peu les salariés allaient mettre tout le
temps dans le dans le boulot et puis
surtout préparer des nouvelles choses
pour la pole a repris aussi
alors comment ça va se passer pour la
réouverture vous êtes déjà prêt on est
déjà prêts comme des i come on est
restés ouverts tous les
les fournisseurs tous les clients sont
restés un petit peu au contact donc pour
ça c'était peut-être un peu plus facile
que pour des restos conduit vraiment
fermer leur frigo ou les frigos sont
restés un minimum ouvert et si on peut
dire si on peut dire ouverts mais au
moins ça il y avait un petit peu de
turnover donc si je pense que c'est plus
facile quand on a fait un petit peu de
travail avant pour ravoir contact avec
les tous les fournisseurs oui alors
justement vous avez une partie
restauration vous avez une partie aussi
bar pub
forcément vous attendez aussi l'euro qui
arrive en juin prochain les matches de
l'euro qui sont diffusées dans votre
établissement
est ce que vous comptez sur cette
période sur les événements sportifs pour
relancer aussi votre activité c'est sûr
que ça va aider vu que on a été arrêtée
pas mal de temps d'avoir un événement
comme le sport qui est conviviale et qui
va rassembler les gens c'est ça va être
quelque chose d'agréable par contre
après il va falloir va falloir faire
attention et garder comme on dit partout
les gestes barrières et ça c'est être
commencé quand on fait de la fête où
quand il ya des buts et c'est en voiture
que ça soit sur les terrains ou à côté
la plupart des gens sont assez convié
conviviaux et puis veulent se touchent
et il va falloir mettre le holà un peu
là-dessus coup alors que c'est ça le
plus complet préparait déjà comment ça
va s'organiser dans son allée télé qui
sont à l'intérieur qui sont déjà prêtes
on met année un écran qui sera dehors
aussi donc ça nous on a l'habitude ça
fait des années qu'on depuis 98 on est
sur les événements sportifs dont c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on sait qu'on
sait faire donc après avec les jauges ça
sera un peu compliqué au début de l'euro
mais c'est vrai que si les français
volants jusqu'en finale on sera quand
même beaucoup plus tranquille parce que
normalement à partir du 30 juin il n'y a
plus de jauger il ya que les gestes
barrière c'est à dire se serre la main
faire la bise et c'est qu'ils vont
rester en vigueur quoi donc ouverture
mercredi 19 mai du uniquement pour la
terrasse ensuite le 9 juin avec le
restaurant dans son intégralité
merci sébastien merci à vous dirigeants
diot dames patty et maintenant on va
aller à quelques mètres d'ici on va se
rendre à la ferme de voisins en 2020 ce
restaurant a perdu 35% de son chiffre
d'affaires pareil comme lausanne pâtit
il va pouvoir rouvrir sa terrasse le 19
mai rencontre avec romain gicquel le
chef de la ferme de voisins
bienvenue à la ferme de voisins je suis
romain gicquel le chef propriétaire des
lieux et je dormais avec moi pour
montrer comment se passera la
réouverture à partir de 19 m comme vous
le constatez on a déjà commencé à mettre
en place notre terrasse on à la
distanciation absolument partout on a
plus d'un médecin ou un mètre cinquante
ans que chaque table on a créé un espace
qui n'existait pas du tout donc on avait
tout cet espace là qui étaient du même
style
à ma gauche et là on a créé un petit
écrin on va pouvoir vous accueillir cet
esprit un petit peu guinguette d'une
table un petit peu à l'écart mais en
terrasse en même temps un petit peu de
verdure un petit peu de soleil
sympa pour partager un moment avec les
copains a profité de cette pause pour
faire un petit peu de travaux réinvestir
sur la terrasse à l'intérieur également
on a fait quelques modifications des
changements de peinture de moquette etc
[Musique]
je vous montre un petit peu la cuisine
en ce moment on est sur du pick and
collect uniquement à partir du 19 mai
nous ferons du click and collect plus la
terrasse si le temps le permet et ce
jusqu'au 9 juin à partir de 9h ou le
talisman complètement midi et soir passé
entre le 19 mai et le 9 20 nous pouvons
accueillir les gens en terrasse que le
midi la cuisine fonctionne déjà
nous allons été qui ont monté en
puissance au fur et à mesure pour
l'instant on a des équipes réduites on
les fait douter que quelques heures par
semaine mais il faut savoir aussi que
depuis le début de l'année on a essayé
de faire bosser toute l'équipe
un certain nombre d'heures par semaine
afin de remettre tout le monde à 100% de
leur salaire
voir nos grands classiques tels que la
sucette de gambas la tête de veau le
baba au rhum qui font partie de notre
carte de nos plats signatures qu'on va
garder quasiment l'année tout en
maintenant et on aura quelques produits
phares tels que la noix de ris de veau
qui est un produit que j'affectionne
particulièrement qui sera aussi est
aussi là pour la rentrée on a des belles
zones de stockage qui sont pour
l'instant vide mais revenez me voir dans
quinze jours et vous verrez qu'on a un
petit peu plus de marchandises comment
prépare-t-on la réouverture au niveau
des stocks bas c'est très simple on
démarre dès maintenant on commence à
bloquer certaines marchandises
on se re met en contact un nouveau avec
nos fournisseurs on explique on a
peut-être besoin de ça a besoin de ça et
après on va être comme d'habitude notre
métier hyper réactif sur la marchandise
et sur la production et on va s'adapter
au fil de l'eau alors la gestion
économique et financière de
l'établissement est très tendue comme
pour tous les collègues restaurateurs
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on a eu
recours à un pelé lieu l'année dernière
pour passer cette période donc autant
vous dire que le pg c'est un prêt
garanti par l'état donc c'est un prêt il
va falloir le rembourser donc on a
l'argent pour on a débloqué de l'argent
pour passer cette période là mais là
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il faut qu'on
redémarre pas ce qu'est un nom et une
question un petit peu de survie de
l'entreprise et de d'euros recréer un
petit peu de trésorerie pourquoi je
remplis les fournisseurs pour que la
machine puisse recevoir correctement
[Musique]
on poursuit ce sky écho au sein de la
zone d'activités de trappes la société
proterra environnement existe maintenant
depuis plus de vingt ans son activité la
mise en place de dispositifs
d'étanchéité pour préserver les sols se
sont par exemple des bassins routier
industrielle ou encore de stockage de
déchets c'est ma vie d'entrepreneur avec
sébastien thomas c'est le dirigeant de
cette entreprise
[Musique]
je sui sébastien thomas ses dirigeants
de protéger l'environnement
société spécialisée dans l'étanchéité
par géo membrane liés aux ouvrages de
protection de l'environnement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le principe c'est de
recueillir l'eau dont des systèmes de
récupération pour éviter de polluer le
milieu naturel
nous réalisons l'étanchéité de bassins
d'eaux pluviales stockage d'eau soit de
ruissellement routiers soit stockage
d'eaux industrielles
on a aussi une activité dans les centres
d'enfouissement technique ce qu'on
appelle vulgairement les décharges
d'ordures ménagères
on travaille principalement dans le nord
et l'ouest de la france c'est cette
activité là on travaille aussi depuis 20
ans à tahiti en nouvelle calédonie dans
l'enfouissement de déchets
principalement celles des grands crus
terrassé par un terrassier nous on vient
à appliquer une jeune géotextile de
protection et ensuite une géo membrane
d'étanchéité avant de créer mon
entreprise j'ai été conducteur de
travaux chez eurovia pendant sept ans 93
de nuit et j'ai travaillé deux ans dans
l'étanchéité juste avant dans une petite
filiale d'eurovia la perche était juste
avant de créer mon entreprise
[Musique]
les défis de demain c'est maintenir une
activité soutenue par rapport à la crise
duc le vide depuis une dizaine d'années
nous constatons quelques difficultés
dans le recrutement de personnel
technique notamment de chefs de chantier
est soudeur
bien que nous les informions en interne
notre défi pour les années à venir c'est
de maintenir un personnel qualifié bien
payés et en même temps de développer
notre activité commerciale a rendez vous
à noter dans vos agendas le mardi 18 mai
le ski qu il organise un webinaire avec
cette question quel souci juridique pour
les entreprises en difficulté
plus d'informations et inscriptions sur
le site qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et l'accompagnement des entreprises en
difficulté c'est le principe du réseau
opérationnel de soutien et d'appui
d'urgence appelée aussi roseaux une
structure dans laquelle la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie est engagé
objectif faire connaître d'entreprise
les procédures juridiques en cas de
difficultés les détails avec guillaume
ferrer il est conseillé entreprises à la
cci de versailles yvelines
[Musique]
concrètement on parle d'entreprises en
difficulté dans le cadre justement dès
lors qu'il ya des échéances financières
qui peinent à être honoré nous
rencontrons aujourd'hui beaucoup de
défaillances justement de paiement
certaine échéance
[Rires]
[Musique]
la première chose à faire c'est de se
poser les bonnes questions et de se
faire accompagner
l'objectif c'est de ne pas être seule
est toujours d'aller chercher en fait
les compétences là où nous avons des
expertises 1 h 30 de commerce nous avons
mis en place un système de réseau avec
un vrai partenariat de tutorat qu'on
appelle le roseau réseau opérationnel de
soutien et d'appui d'urgence qui va être
un outil fort d'accompagnement pour ces
entreprises on appelle en difficulté ou
en phase de rebond
[Musique]
on parle effectivement d'état de
cessation de paiement de liquidation
judiciaire de mandat haddock
toutes ces préventions en fait qu'ils
sont là pour protéger le chef
d'entreprise ne sont pas à considérer de
façon isolée
il vaut mieux aller au centre de
prévention des entreprises qui s'appelle
le csb que nous hébergeons à ses 6 78
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en ripé
sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]